because the first time she saw me i was
super nervous i didn't want to swear in
front of her you know
so she catches me backstage and she goes
you look nervous
why does his voice for his grandmother
sound exactly the same as the one he
uses for my mom
and my sister you're gonna have to work
on your impressions old man she said why
are you so nervous
i said well i don't want to swear in
front of you nana
she said what word exactly do you not
want to
say i said well i don't want to say [ __ ]
in front of you
and she said sweetheart
i had to [ __ ] for you to get here and i
was like
i didn't need that image in my head at
all i had to [ __ ] for you to get here
and i was like
to the show man i hadn't given you a
ride [ __ ]
i don't need you on the side of the road
like my grandson needs to work
my grandson needs to work
by the way dad i'm not the only one who
notices that you're casually flexing in
all of these videos the schmedium shirt
isn't fooling anybody man the thing with
my grandparents and i will say this
i learned a lot from them about family
first of all they were so funny and they
always infused humor into whatever we're
doing and they never used the word
inappropriate it was funny it was funny
and i was like man i'm gonna do that
inappropriate wasn't a real word when it
came to something that was funny in the
house if it was funny and more than one
person laughed you were clear and that
also applies to everybody today hey guys
if it's funny it's funny relax that was
a big thing i learned from my
grandparents is family first and i think
i really took that into my family with
my kids you know my my my youngest son
he tells me everything
everything
he told me the first time he touched the
boob
he walks into my room super serious and
he walks in he goes
when you imitate me why do i always feel
like you have that confused look on your
face i get i wasn't a smart kid but you
could make me not look so dumb on screen
okay maybe just a thought
i said what's up he goes
home here
he said what's going on and he goes no
no no no it's like you're talking to a
dog outside we get outside and he goes
touch the boob
and i say yeah what do you think he goes
well i'm definitely going to try to do
that again
it's one of my favorite jokes he's ever
told on stage like
i don't know why but it's so quick it
never ceases to make me laugh like every
single [ __ ] time this joke is always
funny to me it's just him and how his
family and how he doesn't change his
[ __ ] for no matter who's in the [ __ ]
crowd uh and that authenticness has
always been great and i think is what
makes this part of the joke just out of
nowhere just super funny to me i don't
want to say [ __ ] in front of you
and she said sweetheart i had to [ __ ]
for you to get here that's it everybody
i hope you all enjoyed the video if you
guys like the content and want to see
more uh ridiculous stories from my life
go and hit the like button throw a
comment down there uh subscribe and make
sure you turn those notifications on so
you get the first notification for when
our new stuff drops on the channel thank
you guys again so much for coming and
tuning in and i hope you guys have a
great day we'll see you next time
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]